ce qu on revient maintenant en
nouvelle-zélande où depuis plusieurs
semaines les icebergs se rapproche des
codes des attaques venues du pôle sud et
qui constitue une attraction touristique
les touristes qui viennent notamment en
hélicoptères admirer le spectacle
florence malik après avoir longuement
mûri dans le coeur glacées de
l'antarctique
ce colosse s'est détaché du continent un
autre géant lui tient compagnie un peu
plus loin ces deux icebergs vestiges
d'une énorme montagne de glace ont
commencé leur lente dérive vers la
nouvelle zélande il ya six ans
probablement sous l'effet du
réchauffement climatique
les vents les courants les ont entraînés
dans une descente de 13 mille cinq cents
kilomètres jusqu'aux côtes néo
zélandaises c'est vraiment spectaculaire
on ne voit ça qu'une fois dans sa vie
une aubaine pour les amateurs de
frissons polaire une armada des
hélicoptères déversent depuis plusieurs
jours une cargaison de touristes sur le
dos de ces monstres glacé par france
c'est une couche de glace et quand vous
atterrissez vous devez faire très
attention à ce que l'hélicoptère ne
glisse pas d'abord à l'autre en de
retour sur la terre ferme
la graine d'aventuriers c'est parfois la
fine bouche balen pas dauphin non non et
ne se doute pas à quels dangers elle a
pu échapper car un iceberg c'est loin
d'être inoffensif quatre cinquièmes de
son volume est immergé un cinquième à la
tête hors de l'eau
tout à coup des pans entiers peuvent se
détacher et le mastodonte chaviré ces
derniers jours les icebergs se
rapprocher dangereusement de la nouvelle
zélande
mais la menace s'éloigne les courants
les entraînent plus au large
on connaît leur destin ils finiront par
fondre inexorablement